la banque centrale européenne bouée de
sauvetage de l'économie la bce élargi
son plan de soutien à la zone euro de
500 à 1000 850 milliards la planche à
billets tourne à plein régime pour
permettre aux états plombés par la clé
zuco vide de financer leur quoi qu'il en
coûte mais quelles sont les limites de
cette politique ultra généreuse est
insuffisamment ciblées on en parle tout
de suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir jacques bonsoir stéphanie alors
que faut-il penser des décisions
récemment annoncées par la bce
oui effectivement la banque centrale
européenne a décidé la semaine dernière
de toute une série de mesures
ce sont des décisions qui sont
effectivement très importante parce que
si le plan de soutien à l'économie
décidé par la commission européenne va
mettre maintenant beaucoup de temps à
rentrer en action
on attend rien d'ici l'été prochain
et bien pour l'instant c'est
essentiellement la banque centrale
européenne qui fait le travail et c'est
un point qui est extrêmement important
en fait la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est est-ce que ces actions sont
susceptibles de pouvoir réellement
enrayer la crise économique
alors jacques à vous nourrit donc
l'action la bce est bien plus importante
en fait que le plan de relance européen
750 milliards annoncés cet été
oui tout à fait tout à fait et là il
faut savoir que les différents pays
européens
il avait le choix effectivement entre
des mesures qui seraient des mesures
budgétaires et des mesures monétaires et
en fait ils ont donné la priorité aux
mesures monétaires alors ces mesures
monétaires c'est quoi ce cd garanties de
prêts cds crédit bonifié ses différents
types de crédits spéciaux au total ces
mesures monétaires
elle représente en allemagne en italie
30 % du pib je dis bien 30 % 15 % en
france dès % en espagne en particulier
et on voit que par rapport à ça et bien
les
pense budgétaire reste nettement
inférieur alors jacques est ce à dire
que la bce a largement ouvert le robinet
du crédit pour les états et pour les
banques
oui vous savez de toute manière ça fait
déjà plusieurs années depuis que
monsieur draghi avait parlé de son
fameux bazooka monétaire mais déjà
plusieurs années que la bce avait une
politique que l'on peut considérer comme
laxiste elle avait d'ailleurs cherché à
réduire ses émissions au deuxième
semestre 2010 9 or là évidemment avec la
pandémie de l'aco vide 19
c'est reparti de manière spectaculaire
on le voit la masse monétaire s'accroît
d'un trimestre sur l'autre trimestre de
l'année précédente sur le même trimestre
de l'année précédente
s'accroît grosso modo de 6 à 7% 1
jusqu'à pratiquement 8 % et puis surtout
on voit que les crédits aux états et
bien il augmente de manière considérable
ils ont atteint pour le troisième
trimestre de 2020 un accroissement de
16% et quels sont les instruments
qu'elle utilise alors le premier
instrument
c'est ce que l'on appelle dans le jargon
de la bce
le ppp où le peuple de le le pandémique
puncheur game engine six programmes
c'est un programme de rachat dead de
rachat de titres qui est spécifique à la
pandémie
et c'est justement là où il ya quelque
chose d'important qui s'est passé on a
glissé si vous voulez de 350 milliards à
1850 milliards il ya grosso modo une
semaine jeudi dernier
bon c'est important parce qu'il faut
quand même dire que 1850 milliards de
rachats de titres
c'est l'équivalent pratiquement de 80%
du pib de la france et c'est
effectivement pour l'instant l'un des
principaux instruments de soutien à
l'économie
dont s'est dotée la banque centrale
européenne alors jacques on dit toujours
qu'une banque centrale intervient sur
les taux d'intérêt oui tout à fait vous
avez tout à fait raison
c'est d'ailleurs l'instrument absolument
classique alors il faut toujours
rappeler que normalement la banque
centrale européenne l ajustement à un
objectif d'inflation ou disons une
limite d'inflation de l'ordre de 2%
or justement du fait de la pandémie
nous sommes dans une situation qui est
une situation qui est largement
déflationniste en fait l'inflation est
largement inférieure à 2%
qu'est ce que fait la banque centrale
européenne elle a un taux directeur qui
est à 0%
les autres tous qu'ils sont des taux qui
sont des taux sur des périodes plus
courtes
ils sont même négatif entre -0 50 et 0
25%
néanmoins on voit bien qu'elle ne va pas
pouvoir aller très loin dans cette
direction si vous voulez un taux négatif
à - 2 - 3 % n'est tout simplement pas
possible parce que ça coûterait cher
justement à la bce et donc on voit une
chose c'est que autant l'action parle et
où elle est efficace quand il s'agit de
calmer l'inflation
mais face à la demande face à la
déflation et bien la banque centrale
européenne elle est relativement démunie
et quels sont donc les autres non pardon
à qui profites pardon chargea que cette
politique de la bce
alors eh bien tout d'abord elle profite
évidemment aux états qui justement
profitent de ces rachats et de ses taux
extrêmement faible pour pouvoir se
refinancer
avec un coût très faible elle devrait
aussi profiter aux banques si vous
voulez parce que on voit très bien que
les banques vont être face à un risque
de crédit non performants route en fait
d'impayés sur les sur les crédits qui va
être extrêmement important en 2021 et en
donc normalement ça devrait profiter
essentiellement aux banques
or ce que l'on constate et ça c'est un
point extrêmement intéressant
c'est qu' il n'y a que 25 % des sommes
qui ont été engagés par la bce qui sont
allés aux banques de la zone euro
et quels sont les autres bénéficiaires
ben justement c'est là l'un des
problèmes et qu'ils se posent
on constate quand on regarde ce qui se
passe sur les marchés
on constate que les 75% restants sont
allés à des sociétés financières non
bancaires et surtout des sociétés
financières qui ne se font pas partie de
la zone euro alors peut-être des
sociétés financières britanniques mais
ça peut être aussi des sociétés
financières américaines
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais ça veut
dire que une grande partie de l'argent
que la banque centrale européenne a mis
sur le marché pour aider l'économie
européenne ne va pas justement atteindre
ses objectifs et va plutôt partir en
fond spéculatif et va donc être un
risque potentiel d'instabilité dans les
marchés financiers dans les mois voire
les années à venir alors mais pourquoi
les banques ne bénéficie tels que de 25%
de rachat décidée par la bce dans ce cas
ça c'est effectivement l'une des l'une
des grandes questions s'ils voulaient on
peut déjà dire une chose c'est que la
banque centrale européenne eh bien elle
doit d'une certaine air s'occuper de
tous les pays de la zone euro c'est tout
à fait évident c'est tout à fait normal
bon mais ces pays ont eux mêmes des
situations qui sont extrêmement
divergents
ce qui fait que au lieu de pouvoir avoir
une politique monétaire ciblée comme
aurait une banque centrale nationale
comme a par exemple la banque centrale
du royaume uni la bank of england
bon au lieu d'avoir ce type de politique
ciblée et bien la bce a une politique
d'arrosage générale sur les marchés et
donc il se fait que une grosse partie de
cet argent ne va pas là où ils devraient
aller autrement dit est bien la bce a
peut-être un swing
comme on dit en tennis qui est très
puissant mais il ya beaucoup de trous
dans la raquette
donc en conclusion jacques vous dites
que l'action de la bce qui est la seule
à véritablement agi en réalité est en
partie inefficaces voire contre
productive
oui tout à fait tout avait si vous
voulez je ne critique pas le fait que la
bce agissent parce que il faut toujours
rappeler
elle est la seule à agir dans l'instant
puisque on voit bien que les actions de
soutien budgétaires de la commission
européenne donc de l'europe
eh bien nous commencerons à les voir se
matérialiser qu'à l'été prochain il faut
bien faire quelque chose d'ici là et de
fait la bce est la seule qui soit
capable de le faire mais en même temps
et on voit bien que la bce parce qu'elle
est justement cette banque de l'ensemble
de la zone euro parce qu'elle n'est pas
une banque qui connaissent bien
un pays eh bien elle n'arrive pas à
cibler effectivement une partie de ses
actions dont une partie de l'argent qui
va partir ailleurs qui va partir dans
des sociétés financières qui sont hors
zone euro est d'une certaine manière ce
type de politique ça fait courir un
risque de déstabilisation des marchés
non pas dans l'immédiat évidemment mais
pour l'année prochaine ou dans les deux
ans à venir et bien jacques merci pour
cet éclairage qui en ville on sent les
conséquences un financière à venir de
cette lisea la semaine prochaine